hi dad dad everyone in auradon knows
that he teases mouseka which got us
thinking who's your dad
uma you've been pretty much tight-lipped
about your family tree sure you're the
daughter of Ursula but your abilities
surpass your mother's by a longshot
you're smart resourceful and curious so
you must have found out who your dad is
at some point or another so come on
uma tell us the truth there's way more
to Malan umas relationship than meets
the eye they're stronger together for
some undisclosed reason and we believe
we know why watch until the end to find
out what mal Ouma and Maui have in
common there are two ways Malin Ouma
could be related and they both have to
do with Hades Disney often draws
inspiration from Greek mythology which
is where the Lord of the underworld
originates from when it comes to Greek
mythology Malin Huma aren't related but
when you combine the Disney verse with
the mythological world Puma and Mouse
family tree does in fact cross branches
in the earliest The Little Mermaid
drafts King Triton and Ursula were
brother and sister
and since Hades is train's uncle this
means that he's Ursula as uncle - this
would make human mouth distant cousins
it would also make uma and Ariel first
cousins - although Disney chose omit
Ursula and Triton's relationship from
the movie there are still some subtle
hints that link them together but for
now let's put the Disney verse in Greek
mythology aside and focus on the
descendants world things are very
different in the United States of
auradon and so is the relationship
between Malin umas in this universe
they're much closer than distant cousins
they're half sisters let's look at some
of the facts Malin umer are about the
same age and grew up together on the
Isle of the Lost
who must father has to have lived on the
Isle or her conception wouldn't make
sense
Hades told Malin descendants 3 that
being married to her mother wasn't easy
easiest person to get along with so we
know that Hades and Maleficent got
divorced right around the time that mal
was born so it's possible that Hades
dated around after calling it quits with
Maleficent there are so many clues that
point towards mal and uma being half
siblings one of them being Malin umas
instant connection since childhood but
something happened for Mau to suddenly
turn on Emma in the novel rise of the
Isle of the Lost and we're thinking
Maleficent had a hand in this Maleficent
must have known about Hades and Ursula's
fling which would make her despise uma
so separating uma and mal would have
been a top priority and since mal was
keen on making her mother proud she
probably didn't think twice before
betraying uma being able to transform
into fantastical beasts is another theme
these two BK's have in common
uma can turn into a sack a Lia she can
control water and you see magic and Mao
can turn into a fire-breathing dragon
both uma and mal can use complicated
spells and uma can even use spells right
out of mouths Belva that doesn't sound
like sea magic to us Malin amar are the
only BK's in auradon who can transform
into large creatures in the blink of an
eye
sure they might get this from their
mother's side of the family but if mal
and uma were only half magical why would
they be stronger than their mothers it
sounds like they have some other powers
of play here which likely come from
their shared father Hades we also
noticed that Malin uma have similar hair
colors although Maleficent doesn't show
her hair she's known for repping the
color purple so we can only assume that
she has a head of purple hair like
mouths Katie's hair is vibrant blue put
those together and you get mouths purple
blue hair centers uma her mother Ursula
was voiced by Whoopi Goldberg in
descendants to
[Music]
so we can only imagine that Ursula has
dark skin and white hair but Houmas hair
is a mix of white black and blue so
where does this mysterious blue color
come from we're pointing a finger at
Hades but the most obvious sign that uma
and mal are sisters has to do with Hades
amber before giving mal his number Hades
told her that it only responded fully to
him because he's a God
the amber won't do everything for you
that it does but for some odd reason uma
and mal were able to use the amber to
its full potential when together now
didn't accomplish this with edj or
Carlos but when it came to Emma magic
happened on top of that
uma seashell necklace was also reacting
to mal so maybe it's since their close
relationship Malin uma quickly realized
that they were strong together but they
never explained why and guys we doubted
us to do with the power of love or
friendship because if that were the case
mal wouldn't have needed whom had to
save auradon Katie's told mal that if
she got the Ember wet it would be game
over yet somehow she managed to revive
it with umas ho now couldn't ignite the
Ember alone she could only use it at
half capacity but if mal and humor are
truly Haiti's daughters that makes them
both demigods and the power of two
demigod should equal out to the power of
one this explains why Malin uma were
able to do what they did
and luckily Audrey in the scepter were
no match for Emma and mouse powers
combined do you guys think that mal and
whom are half sisters cousins were
simply unrelated tell us in the comment
section and thanks for watching hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
catch you later
[Music]